- I feel we are overusing
the resources of our planet.
We want to expand the
possibilities of agriculture
in an environment where it wasn't thought
that you could actually grow plants.
We think that that can really change
the outlook for the future.
(atmospheric music)
(pleasant music)
Nemo's Garden is an
alternative agriculture project
where we are trying to find a way to grow
plants underwater in
underwater greenhouses.
We have grown between 50
and 60 different species:
basil, different kinds of salads,
goji, soy, sprouts, medical herbs.
Harvesting the plants
is actually very simple.
We cut it just like we would do on land,
and then we wrap it into
reusable plastic containers
and we just close it up and we pick it
up on the surface nice and comfortable.
The main challenges of
growing plants underwater are:
it has never been done; it's all new.
Initially, the learning
curve was very steep.
Every operation has to
be done scuba diving,
and that is a challenge on itself.
The main advantages are the
protection from outside elements.
We are underwater, nothing can get to us.
No pests, means no chemicals needed,
and, of course, no hail, no storms,
the temperature stability
that we have inside the water,
which is a lot more stable than outside.
Plus the higher pressure
underwater, apparently,
makes our plants grow faster and stronger
and with higher contents
of essential oils.
The water that we use for the plants
is mostly from evaporation of
the surface of the saltwater.
Once it's evaporated it
condenses back into rain.
We basically create
freshwater automatically
that we don't need to
consume any energy for.
(soft piano music)
We know that climate change
and the future of demography
is headed towards a way where we will be
overusing the resources of our planet.
I hope that Nemo's Garden
is a way to use those
resources in a very respectful
way and balanced way.
The whole concept for
the project is to expand
the possibilities of agriculture.
In a world that is covered
more than 70 percent in water
it simply made sense to us.
(electronic music)